selbst der nebel über der weichsel
leuchtet in weiß und rot
das sind polens nationalfarben unten
marschieren männer keine veteran sondern
junge leute für die unabhängigkeit so
als ob sie noch errungen werden müsste
dazu skandieren sie gott ehre vaterland
die straßen von warschau gehören den
nationalisten aber nur für diesen tag
dieser marsch erinnert an den tag im
jahre 1918 als polen endlich wieder
nation sein durfte
davor war es über 100 jahre von der
landkarte verschwunden weil die großen
nachbarn es so wollten man ist homophob
und zwar offen man mag weder muslime
noch den feminismus und hält die
nationalkonservative regierung für
waschlappen nicht alle hier sind
parteigänger der rechten es gibt auch
unvoreingenommenen beobachter
[Musik]
gerade hier in dieser demo wird der
polnischen regierung vorgeworfen sie
seien unter zehn ich gegenüber dem
gegenüber größeren gegenüber washington
und polens seien nicht
selbst wenn ich nicht
ja nicht selbständig
ein halbes dutzend organisationen von
rechtsextremisten haben sich zu einer
konföderation zusammengetan und auf
anhieb 7 prozent der wähler hinter sich
versammelt das ist ein problem für die
regierung die eigentlich rechts von sich
nichts entstehen lassen das motto des
jahres zeigt einen ritter der mit seinem
schwert einen stern zerschmettert der
stern ist zur hälfte rot und zur hälfte
in regenbogenfarben
wer so denkt sieht sich ständig von
feinden umgeben von der notwendigkeit
gesprochen aufzustehen selbständiges
volk zu werden sich vor fremden mächten
zu verteidigen also immer eine rhetorik
vielleicht im neunzehnten jahrhundert
oder auch im kommunismus angebracht
gewesen wäre aber heute eben nicht mehr
eigentlich dürften sich in polen gerade
nur fünf leute versammeln der
bürgermeister er links hat die
demonstration verboten die regierung
drückt ein auge zu
ein autokorso als ausweg die in den
autos sind die besseren demonstranten da
kann man sich wenigstens nicht anstecken
immer wieder müssen die krankenwagen
sich gassen bahn ständig explodieren
knallkörper in dem dicht gedrängten zug
und einige raketen landen auch im
wohnzimmer
die polizei wartet in den seitenstraßen
auf die üblichen steinewerfer viele
beamte so heißt es haben sich krank
gemeldet
und doch ist dieser marsch sagt der
langjährige beobachter sowie patrick nur
ein abklatsch seiner selbst die treuen
fußballfans fehlen
es gibt internen krach normalerweise
sind die fußballfans auf seiten der
regierung einigen passt aber die
richtung nicht
das neue abtreibungsverbot spaltet die
fußballfans und deshalb sind
möglicherweise einige zu hause geblieben
simo wird ist als eher linker
schriftsteller von anfang an dabei und
so weiß er dass der nationalismus seine
grenzen hat das lustige ist dass sie
nach dem unabhängigkeits marsch
gemeinsam einen döner essen
[Musik]
man würde polen wünschen dass sie ihre
unabhängigkeit eines tages feiern können
als fest der freude und nicht als mal
ein paar tage zuvor dort wo warschau vor
allem schön und majestätisch ist bekam
die bischöfe abends überraschend besuch
es war bestimmt kein zufall dass die
demonstrantinnen und demonstranten erst
vor das episkopat zogen und sich die
polizei davor in stellung brachte und
danach vor den präsidentenpalast die
kirche und die regierende partei recht
und gerechtigkeit pis bilden eine
allianz und viele glauben dass sie schon
in einem gottesstaat leben wo die kirche
die gesetze macht wenn noch immer denkt
polens wähler sein frommer als dilemma
und katholischer als der papst der war
länger nicht mehr vor ort
ich habe angst dass dies der erste
schritt zu größeren einschränkungen ist
ich habe zwei töchter im teenageralter
und ich will dass sie die wahl haben
es geht ja nicht um wunsch abtragen baum
soll ich einen toten fötus zur welt
bringen
der frauen streik hat den polen
tradition von 2016 gelang es das halbe
land auf die beine zu bringen
der rote blitz ist ihr symbol eine der
führenden köpfe des frauen streiks ist
die juristin und frühere beamten martha
lampard weil sie öffentlich ein megaphon
benutzte hat sie eine anklage wegen
umweltverschmutzung am hals 1 von 40
verfahren
was ist nur los in polen da haben sie
wohl eine kleine revolution angezettelt
warum redet alle welt von einer kleinen
revolution wohl weil wir frauen sind
dabei wollen wir die regierung stürzen
wenn man nur die köpfe zählt dann ist
das liberale weltoffene polen auf dem
vormarsch in warschau waren es
hunderttausende
aber auch in den kleinen orten auf dem
lande dem stammland der regierung gegen
frauen und einige männer auf die straße
hat die pis vielleicht den anschluss an
die junge generation verloren
jedenfalls an den weiblichen teil fragen
wir einen führenden konservativen
das ist eine wichtige und sehr
gefährliche soziale entwicklung
die junge generation ist sehr gespalten
die jungen frauen gehen nach links und
die jungen männer nach rechts in ein
paar jahren kommt die zeit familien zu
gründen
aber wie soll das gehen wenn sie
weltanschaulich soweit auseinander das
oberste verfassungsgericht hat sein
übriges um den kulturkampf richtig
anzufachen
die pis und die kirchen applaudierten es
gab einigen jubel bei den gruppen von
radikalen abtreibungsgegnern
polen bedeutet das leben wenn wir unsere
kinder nicht umbringen wird polen
wachsen
aber es gab auch andere ernsthafte
fragen fern von jeder polemik wie weit
trägt die fürsorge des staates wenn die
kinder erst mal auf der welt sind und
davor
es ist nicht wahr dass die regierung
sich um die kinder vor der geburt
kümmert das tut sie einfach nicht es ist
enorm schwierig einen termin beim
frauenarzt zu bekommen oder auch nur
informationen gerade jetzt in zeiten der
pandemie wenn frauen von kindern in den
krankenhäusern getrennt werden
niemand kümmert sich um frauen vor oder
nach der geburt sie kümmern sich nur um
den fötus was zuvor im katholischen kern
land polen und vorstellbar war
es gab protestaktion in kirchen und
schutz staffeln von rechtsextremen vor
der tür mit rückendeckung von ganz oben
wir müssen vor allem unsere polnischen
kirchen verteidigen
wir müssen sie um jeden preis
verteidigen ich rufe alle peace
mitglieder und alle unsere unterstützer
auf die kirchen zu verteidigen
eine straße im norden warschau hier
wohnt jaroslaw kaczynski der mächtigste
mann polens allein mit seiner katze vor
seinem haus patrouillieren polizisten
sie müssen verhindern dass unflätige
schilder an seinem zaun gehängt werden
sonst droht ihnen einen verweis
also wenn er hier aus diesem haus aus
dem fenster schaut sieht er vor allem
diese blüte das ist überhaupt ein
bisschen leer um ihn herum auch in der
politik jahrelang hatte aber auch dafür
gearbeitet er hat sich isoliert in
europa auch in polen hat er nicht mehr
hat er das gefühl verloren für das was
in diesem land geschieht kaczynski ist
bei den nachbarn nicht unbedingt populär
ich hoffe dass es neue proteste geben
wird
dass sie so schnell nicht aufgeben haben
sie teilgenommen ja natürlich habe ich
teilgenommen
und wie war es wo man konnte solidarität
spüren das war sehr schön
[Musik]
die sprüche gegen die pis lassen nichts
an deutlichkeit vermissen geht zum
teufel oder fahr zur hölle
wenn man es höflich formulierend polen
am wendepunkt auch männer sind dabei
auch solche die sich selbst als moderne
konservative bezeichnen
wie der deutsche der seit einigen jahren
hier wohnt seine polnische frau nahm ihn
mit wir müssen dahin gehen ich glaube
das ist ein ganz besonderer moment und
wir bereuen ist wenn ich da gewesen sind
das ist ein ganz das war doch spürbar
eine bisher nicht da gewesen es gab
vorher proteste eine bisher nicht
dagewesene bisher nicht dagewesene
allgemeine unzufriedenheit eine wut und
ich glaube tatsächlich dieses dieses
abtreibungs entscheidung kann hier der
der letzte die letzte entscheidung
gewesen sein dieser hinsicht weil
einfach hier die leute dass dessen
überdrüssig sind dass hier ein
funktionierender kompromiss einfach mal
nen haufen geworfen wird
unsere nächste station ist danzig
frühmorgens im zug durch ein land das
sich unter der pandemie duckt kein
mensch im speisewagen danzig hat
warschau eine erfahrung voraus man weiß
dass worte töten können januar 2009 10
eine stadt nimmt abschied von ihrem
bürgermeister ein meer von kerzen
sie bilden ein herz hier auf der
früheren lenin-werft die so wie damals
geboren und der bürgermeister stand für
diesen teil von co seine frau magdalena
ist nur in die politik gegangen um gegen
den hass zu kämpfen was genau den
attentäter antrieb was jemand gegen
ihren mann haben konnte pawel adamowicz
war seit 20 jahren bürgermeister seine
letzten worte sind auf den gedenkstein
gemeißelt danzig ist großzügig ganz ich
teilt das gute an sich ist der
wundervollste ort der welt wenige
sekunden später kam der anschlag er
stand auf der bühne der größten
polnischen wohltätigkeitsveranstaltungen
der countdown lief
alle waren abgelenkt staaten in den
himmel
ein vorbestrafter mann drängte sich auf
die bühne und stach mehrmals auf dem
bürgermeister an
danach rief er ich habe fünf jahre
unschuldig im gefängnis gesessen
die partei des bürgermeisters hat mich
gefoltert
magdalena geht auf den wegen die ihr
mann übernahm
meistens ging er zu fuß ins amt er war
äußerst populär heute bis zu 70 prozent
der stimmen einige menschen kannten
bereits seine strecke wenn sie etwas
erleben wollten oder einfach kontakt
standen sie beispielsweise an der ampel
und zebrastreifen und sagt lieber herr
bürgermeister und er habe immer
angehalten
ob er feinde hatte sicher war dass er
den machtmenschen der pis regierung im
fernen warschau ein dorn im auge war
weil an ihm in danzig vorbei nichts ging
in der berühmten marienkirche in der die
streikenden arbeiter damals zuflucht und
beistand gefunden haben ist der ruheort
des bürgermeister lena adamovich
vermeidet es an den mörder zu denken sie
sagt sie müsse stark sein für ihre
kinder was sie wohl angetrieben hat ich
denke dass er ein werkzeug war das
benutzt wurde im rahmen gewisser
mechanismen mechanismen die in der
ganzen welt funktionierenden deutschland
in polen in russland erwachsener
populismus eine zynische lust macht
auszunutzen
eines der größten projekte des
bürgermeisters was an die aufstände der
werftarbeiter zu erinnern und ein ort
des dialogs an die stätte der
untergegangenen werk zu bauen
das european center of solidarity im
zweiten stock residiert lech walesa das
klima zwischen ps und den soli davos
zentrum ist so schlecht dass die
regierung noch nicht mal zum geburtstag
gratuliert niemand kann das so drastisch
kommentieren wie der hausherr
friedensnobelpreisträger und präsident
die kämpfe gegen sie sogar mit meinen t
shirts mit dem was draufsteht verfassung
jeden tag tragen weil sie die verfassung
missachten und das kann ich nicht
zulassen dass sind populisten das sind
kleine leute aber sehr frech mit den
alten herren und weggefährten wie verona
und kaczynski auf beiden seiten gibt es
keine versöhnung
und ob sich die jungen frauen und männer
zusammenraufen können drohen steht
wieder einmal vor einer wende
[Musik]